hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
ancient schools of philosophy that did
in fact have quite a few physical and
metaphysical doctrines that Aristotle is
going to examine fairly closely in
metaphysics book 1 is that associated
with Pythagoras we call it the
Pythagorean school and it's a little bit
difficult to tell which things were
directly coming from Pythagoras for
example the Pythagorean theorem that you
probably have come across in algebra
classes because it was a sort of a
close-knit community that often tended
to attribute to their founder some of
the doctrines of the school and
Pythagoras is several hundred years
before Aristotle so he talks instead
about the pythagorean's and what it is
that they teach as a contemporary school
in his own setting so he says that they
are doing a kind of enterprise that
that's different than many of the more
physically oriented philosophers who
attribute things to say the elements or
you know other things along those lines
because Pythagoras and his followers he
credits them with having discovered
mathematics and having developed that
that science we don't
worry about that but they certainly made
extensive use of it they think that
mathematics is the basis of everything
and so you know this is an idea that
that has not died with the Pythagorean
school by any means we still see people
saying things like this at the present
so he says that through studying
mathematics they came to believe that
the principles the RTI the the you know
the beginning ruling factors you could
say were the principles of everything
not just mathematics but everything else
and we're going to talk about that in
just a moment what those look like says
since numbers are by nature first among
these principles number is Audrey's
moyer right he said that they fancy that
they could detect in numbers to a
greater extent than in the elements like
fire earth and water many analogs of
what is and comes into being so they
ended up extending the consideration of
number not just to the physical world
but also to moral matters or phenomena
he mentions for example a certain
property of number being justice another
being soul or mind and other being
opportunity Cairo Co the right time
right and so they they view all of these
things as either being numbers
themselves or as being functions or
modes of of numbers and they
systematically extend their theory to
try to cover everything this is another
central aspect of philosophy it attempts
to be systematic so he says since they
they saw that properties and ratios of
musical scales are based on numbers and
since it seemed clear that all of the
things have their whole nature modelled
on numbers and that numbers are the
ultimate things in the whole physical
universe they assumed the elements of
numbers to be the elements of everything
and the entire universe to be a
proportion or number so this is a
point of view and a project that has
very universal scope they really are
trying to extend their theory to
everything and I'll give you some
examples of what he tells us about them
giving a bit of summary he says the
elements of number are the even and the
odd of these the former is limited that
is the even and the odd are unlimited
unity consists of both since it's both
odd and even numbers derived from unity
and numbers comprise the whole universe
and then he said others of this same
school hold that there's ten principles
a decade right which they enunciate in a
series of corresponding pairs now notice
as we go through these that some of
these are going to be physical matters
and some of these are going to be moral
matters and there's others that are a
little bit harder to classify limits and
the unlimited okay very basic stuff odd
and even so here we're still in the
level of numbers unity and plurality
there's a pair as well right and left
male and female biological sex rest and
motion metaphysical principle straight
and crooked light and darkness let me
get to good and evil moral phenomena
square and oblong and so you know you
you might come up with all sorts of
other instances of numbers like that you
maybe there could have been 20 there
could have been any amount but what we
see here is an attempt to try to explain
everything on the basis of opposites and
numbers now Aristotle has some
criticisms one of the big criticisms
that he has is that they discussed and
defined the what of things the Peter
they discussed pierre e to TS dean that
the Totti esteem is what a thing is what
it is for it to be but he says they did
so superficially so that they didn't
really end up
explaining what things were he said they
suppose the essence of a thing is that
to which the term under consideration
first applies and so as an example of
this he says they thought that double
and the number two are the same and
they're clearly related to each other
right
but double and two are not exactly the
same thing
he says they thought this because two is
the first number which is double another
but you know eight is also a double a
double of four so double and two are not
exactly the same thing so that's an a
good example of how they didn't define
things all that well even when it came
to numbers themselves another criticism
that he's going to give as well has to
do with you know if they're constructing
everything out of these numbers and
numbers are really something that our
eternal this is this shows you why it
would be attractive to try to explain
things in terms of numbers the problem
with that is it's hard then to use
numbers to explain how you get motion or
change or generation or destruction
now they do in fact have an account of
the universe that says that you know
things are generated out of the 1 for
example but how exactly that's going to
take place on the basis of numbers alone
really no good explanation for that you
need some other principles to be brought
in and the pythagorean's are reducing
everything else to mathematics so it's
hard to see how you're going to get that
and you know that's that's going to be a
significant problem he also tells us
that there's a deeper metaphysical
problem in it might even be viewed as a
logical problem number is being made
both the basis and substance the lúcia
as he says elsewhere in in this this
section of everything so the universe
itself is in fact coming out of or is a
function of number and yeah
number is also the plurality of what
exists so the numbers are supposed to be
what's what's existing and then there's
all these things that are also there so
what you know you're making as one
commentator put it you're making the
basis of reality and reality the same
thing and within which case why are you
talking about even having a basis maybe
you know we need to flatten out the
account a bit along with this there's
some weird assertions that the
pythagorean's make that are kind of
similar to the decade that we just
discussed earlier and and Aristotle
raises some puzzles about this he says
when they make out that opinion Doak saw
an opportunity Kairos are in
such-and-such a region and a little
above or below them injustice and
separation or mixture and when they
state as a proof of this that each of
these abstractions is a number and that
also in this region there's a plurality
of the magnitudes composed of numbers
what's what's actually going on there
how can we make you know sense of this
it seems rather arbitrary and in some
respect that that would be a problem
because this is supposed to be an
intelligible account so you know
according to Aristotle at least the
pythagorean's they're doing some very
interesting stuff but it can't really be
a true account because of all of these
problems that we've noted with the
account that they're providing
you